I'm Doug Marks. I've been Scoutmaster of 251 in Turlock, California, for 18 years.
This addition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by Packers like us.
Thanks, Mark, Appreciate all you do.
And now for you, Scoutmaster
Doug, thanks so much for being a backer and thank you for serving Scouting
And for doing it for 18 years as Scoutmaster. Good for you.
If you want to be coming back, you're going to find out how a little bit later on,
But before we get started, yes, I want to talk about the weather again,
Because, wow, the weather has really been something around here:
Lots of snow, very cold temperatures.
As a matter of fact, the old man was heard to say this on our last camp out
And it ain't a fit night out of man or beast.
And it's true, It was true, Not a fit night out for man nor beast.
Thank you, Mr Fields.
Hey, this is podcast number 209. Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green
And, if you haven't already been able to figure it out, I got a little bit of a cold today.
But hey, we're going to soldier right on ahead
And we're going to start by looking in the mailbag.
Matt Rosenfeld is a unit commissioner in the Pathfinder District
with the Crossroads of America Council in Indiana.
He wrote in to say: I want to thank you for all the useful information you provide on your podcast.
I recently was a recipient of the district award of merit for the work I do as a unit commissioner.
My first reaction upon hearing that I was going to receive the award was that I'm just doing my job.
Why me?
Upon further thought, I think I have you to thank for the award.
As a commissioner, I am constantly sharing the information you discuss on the podcast with other leaders.
When I go to visit my units, it's interesting to hear what other units go through
and the different dynamics of how other units function.
I'm able to share what I learned in your podcast with other people
and it really does make a difference in their program.
I just wanted you to know I appreciate the time you spend with the podcast and the website.
First off, of course, congratulations on the district award of merit,
And it sounds to me like they picked the right guy, because you know,
actually the right guy you give an award to should have exactly that reaction, right?
I'm just doing my job.
Well, apparently you're doing an excellent job, and thank you for your kind comments there.
I'm really happy to find that we are doing things that are useful to other people
and they are making a difference in the program.
And speaking of that, if you weren't able to join us last night for our February scout circle,
do make sure to go to scoutmastercgcom and watch that presentation.
Last night we had as our guest Enoch Hysie-
And Enoch, as you know, is the author of our Green Bar Life Post
And these are aimed at youth leaders
And I was really pleased to be able to have him as a guest on scout circle
and to talk a little bit about youth leadership
and for him to be able to answer questions from other youth leaders
who did show up and did watch the whole thing and they had some great questions
And I think Enoch had some really good replies.
One of the things I think that we can offer that I think is an important resource
is a place for youth leaders to be able to get together and talk,
kind of share ideas and challenges and triumphs and things like that.
Now we're getting off the ground with it.
We've got a forum set up, a Green Bar Life Forum.
We've got Enoch doing some really excellent writing
that I think can be a real help for youth leaders.
And remember, Enoch is 19 years old.
He's recently been a youth leader himself.
He's a well-spoken young man who writes really, really well.
So if you haven't already looked in,
check out the Green Bar Life Post on ScoutMasterCGcom
and share them with your youth leadership
and see if you can get them interested in joining in this conversation
And the scout circle presentations. they happen once a month.
We aim at the second Sunday.
We had to move it this month.
They're a live presentation.
It lasts about an hour.
It begins nine o'clock Eastern time
And I am joined by my co-host, Arlen Ward,
who is out there in Colorado,
And Arlen pointed out that we started doing these presentations last February.
Now we haven't done them every single month over the past year,
but we've done nine or 10 of them.
I think they've proven to be a pretty useful resource.
I finally found a chat application that works.
I'm going to overestimate how difficult what would seem to be a really simple thing can be,
But I was really pleased with the way that that worked last night
and look forward to some more events like this coming up in the future
and maybe just some chat evenings where we'll open up a chat room
and people can come on and we can have discussions about a particular subject.
If that interests you, get in touch with me at Clark at ScoutMasterCGcom.
Let me know how you would like to see that unfold and we'll make it happen.
Now, one of the reasons we can kind of spread our wings a little bit
and expand our offering is because of the people who become ScoutMasterCGcom backers.
If you are a regular reader or listener and you're finding what's offered by ScoutMasterCGcom
to be helpful to you, you can return the favor by helping us keep things up and running
by becoming a backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses of producing and publishing the blog posts
and the podcasts and the Scout Circle presentations and the chat application
that we used in there- all that kind of stuff.
It doesn't cost a mint of money, but it does cost something.
And this week my personal thank you to Mark Engel, who became a backer
since last week's podcast.
In this week's podcast we're going to talk in ScoutMasterCG in seven minutes
or less about the relationship between citizenship and leadership,
And then I have an email question to answer and that's going to take up the remainder
of my kind of croaking through this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Scout MasterCG in seven minutes or less?
When Ben Powell started the scouting movement, one of the things he had his eye on
was helping young people learn the benefits and responsibility of being good citizens.
And I want to talk a little bit about the relationship between being a good citizen
and being a good leader,
Because I think the two are kind of synonymous. a good leader and a good citizen
both have a sense of individual responsibility
and the desire to be of service to others.
I think when we engage youth in leadership,
we are engaging them in learning the skills of citizenship.
Now, naturally, we aren't all destined to become leaders in the classic sense of the term
by directing others or leading a group.
There's much more to leadership than simply being in command,
And I think leadership has four basic components.
The first component of leadership is tied very closely to the Scout motto:
be prepared, because that component of leadership is self-leadership.
Before you lead anybody else, you have to be able to care for your own
spiritual, mental and physical needs.
If Scouts don't care for themselves, if we don't care for ourselves,
we end up limiting our preparedness and our ability to help others.
So the first person we lead is ourselves.
And then the next component that builds on this is leading by following,
by doing your best
And following cooperatively requires a positive attitude
and positive actions that actually contribute to what's going on.
The next component is assisting leadership:
Not just looking after ourselves, not just following,
but assisting our fellow Scouts and Scouters by being kind and friendly
and helpful at every opportunity,
Looking for opportunities to serve other people.
And then, finally, the fourth component is directive leadership.
Scouts who lead themselves and follow cooperatively
and help their fellow Scouts are prepared to become directive leaders.
And directive leaders- that's a classic kind of leader,
The guy with the patch on his shoulder, whether it's a patrol leader
or a senior patrol leader. these are the people that you look to
for direction and leadership and definition as to what's happening.
It's not a choice of whether you want to be a leader or not.
All of the Scouts are leaders in one way or another.
You can't be a Scout without being a leader.
In our younger Scouts we want them to have the ability
to look beyond themselves and to see how their actions
and attitudes affect others.
We help them associate good actions and attitudes
with the Scout Oath and Law
And we help them develop that first component,
that self-leadership.
We want them to have a growing sense of basic altruism
and the desire to serve others and to lead
by being a cooperative follower.
We see the evidence of that when they start to find satisfaction
in helping others more than just fulfilling
their own needs and wants and desires.
In our younger Scouts they have great capacity
for assisting leadership, to help with simple tasks
and to work cooperatively together.
And that all builds onto that directive leadership
where they can take on direct roles.
Now they might not take on a direct role
as the guy that wears the patch.
They can lead in games and ceremonies and activities
with the help of older Scouts and appropriate oversight.
And in our older Scouts we want that self-leadership idea
to be very strong.
We want them to have a strong sense of how their actions
and attitudes affect others
And to be readily able to associate the Scout Oath
and Law with their actions and attitudes.
Cooperation and readiness to help others
should come with little or no prompting.
They should have a heightened sense of fairness and empathy
and be growing more and more tolerant
and accepting of different points of view
and levels of ability.
In our older Scouts the ideals of service
and cooperation are strong.
Assisting with leadership comes very naturally to them.
They should have some pride and group accomplishments
over individual achievements
and they associate their well-being
with the well-being of everybody around them.
And those first three components-
that ability to lead yourself,
the ability to be cooperative
and the ability to lend a hand-
all form the fourth component,
which is that directive leadership.
I think we're successful in building good citizens
and good leaders,
not so much necessarily gauging by metrics
the things that result from their leadership.
That can certainly be an important indicator.
What we're looking for are Scouts
that have the moral and ethical obligations
of the Scout, Oath and Law-
as a central guiding point in their lives.
They're welcoming, supportive and helpful
towards their fellow Scouts
and confident in their outlook and relationships.
They have fully formed ideals of service
and they readily subordinate their needs
to the needs of others.
They have a desire to offer help
and to make a difference
And they have a keen sense of responsibility
to lead fairly and well,
with little or no oversight.
And we want to order things
in our mentoring and advising
so that they feel as though
they can seek advice and assistance
and we can help them get on the right track.
Nobody can be a Scout without being a leader,
even at the very basic level
of just leading yourself,
And I think we need to recognize that
and recognize that development in our Scouts
and help them develop those four components of leadership:
The self-leadership, cooperative leadership,
assisting leadership
and then assuming a position of responsibility
where they have some directive leadership involved.
In doing that,
we are making a fantastic contribution
to every community that they're involved in.
We're building good citizens
and we're achieving
the aims of Scouting.
I'm Kevin Callan, the Happy Camper,
And you're listening to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Write me a letter,
send it by name.
Email: that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I'm Kevin Callan, the Happy Camper,
And you're listening to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Write me a letter,
send it by name.
Here's an email question
And the sender has asked to remain anonymous.
A scout preparing for his Eagle Border review
in my troop
received this email from the District Advancement Chairman.
It said:
I will be conducting your Eagle Border review
And I'd like you to be in uniform
And please bring your Merit badges
and your Boy Scout handbook
In previous boards of review.
this District Advancement Chair
has sent me an email.
I'm Kevin Callan
and this District Advancement Chair
has suggested that Scouts cannot pass
because they don't have a handbook with them,
because they didn't include a permission slip
for the Eagle Project and other
rather insignificant details. to my mind,
In the end,
after much pontificating,
he does allow Scouts to pass
their Border review,
but I can't help but feeling
that he doesn't really get it.
Spoken to our Council Advancement Chair several times
and I'm aware that other troops
have the same attitude to issue with him.
Where do we go from here?
The first thing we do when we have any question
like this is naturally
we run to the resource and I'm sending everybody
to the Guide to Advancement.
read about Eagle Boards of Review.
There's no direction or requirement
that a Scout brings anything with him to a board
other than himself dressed neatly.
There's no requirement to have a uniform,
There's no requirement to have a handbook
And there's certainly no requirement
to bring all your Merit badges with you.
What I'm thinking is that they get
to kind of have Scouts run
the gauntlet when they sit down
for an Eagle Board of Review.
The Guide to Advancement characterizes
the Eagle Board of Review as, yes,
it's an evaluative tool.
The other aspect of it is
is: it's a chance for us to find out
what kind of a job
we've done as Scouts
And to see if we've hit the mark,
not to take an Eagle Candidate
and run him through a gauntlet
or something kind.
It's pretty natural to assume that Scouts
are going to be somewhat nervous
and reticent to approach
something called a Board of Review.
If you get reviews at work,
that might not be your favorite day
to sit down with your boss
and go through a review,
And I think that an Enlightened
District Advancement Chair
would understand those things.
But this one sounds like he's a little
off of True North.
He's going to challenge that attitude
And if nobody cares enough
to put this to a stop
or replace the person in this position,
he's going to keep on doing what he's doing.
If the District Chairman won't tell him,
if the Council Advancement Chairman won't tell him,
maybe the next step
is to talk to the Council Commissioner.
Commissioners are pretty good at working
with things like this
And if the issue still doesn't get resolved,
well you know, the Council President
and the Council Executive may want to know
what's going on.
I've been in the same sort of situation before
and it is terribly frustrating.
If I knew them what I knew now
by basically, you know,
looking at the Guide to Advancement.
I would have been able to resolve the issue
with Eagle Boards of Review
a little bit faster
and without quite so much frustration,
because we have this excellent resource
that really just puts down
in black and white
how they're supposed to be administered.
that well, they need to get in line
with the policy and get with the program,
don't they?
And sometimes all it takes is somebody with a little backbone
insisting that things need to change.
I hope that helps give some direction
to answering the question
and resolving the issue.
If you have a question or an issue or a comment,
hey, I'd love to have you get in touch with me
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much
for listening to this
209th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch:
Go to the blog at
scoutmasterscgcom
and you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
There's a contact form there.
You can get in touch with us. that way
You can get the Scoutmaster CG app.
It's available on Google Play
or through the iTunes App Store-
and that'll keep everything right there at your fingertips
on your mobile device.
You can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Join the 4,800 folks
who like Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus
of 930 tweeters on Twitter.
or, here we go,
pin the PULTURATEDNESS pictures, profited publicly,
with 1,300 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us, if you dare,
on scoutmastercg on YouTube.
Make sure to check out the latest
Scout circle that we recorded just last night,
And you can join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive
Scoutmaster CG circle on Google+.
If you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google+,
that's alright. monkey,
You can email me.
That's right. zoom into the late 90s,
and that is clark.
at scoutmastercgcom,
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Did you know that the Scoutmaster
Blog and the Scoutmaster
Podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America?
Nope, they're not even endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization,
because I'm pretty sure they have
more important things to do.
Now it's just me talking into a microphone
to the wonderful people who become
scoutmastercgcom backers,
and we have a lot of fun doing this.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.